[Music]
mallory's with us in los angeles hi
mallory how are you hi i'm doing good
thanks so much for taking my call
sure what's up so um my father
is dating a woman in ukraine who's about
half his age
they've been dating three years now but
it's gone to the point that he's
spending his money recklessly on her
and he lost his job during covid now
he's working as a driver
and i'm just really concerned for his
financial safety
he's been um he just bought her a new
car in ukraine
she's been paying for her rent giving
her monthly income
and i need some advice on how to address
the situation and help him because i'm
really concerned at this point
how old is he he's 56
and she's about 32 and you are how old
i'm 25. okay well i'm with you
i mean this does not sound good how many
times has he actually been
in the presence of this woman i would
say about three times a year
usually they meet abroad on vacation
together but he pays for that trip
obviously himself um
but i wasn't so concerned about it first
i really thought you know
it's going to be a short relationship
he's going to wake up soon but
where's your mom their divorce she's um
she's still how long how long have they
been divorced
oh about five years now okay but they're
still good friends yeah um
he's just lonely and got stupid i think
so yeah
yeah because you think you think he's
getting conned and so do i
i mean this is like a mail-order russian
bride stereotype thing or something this
is like something you read about right
it's really your dad we've gone to the
situation where
it's real in his mind and i don't want
to damage our relationship at this point
so i'm just trying to support him but at
this point now he just bought a new car
and yeah that's danger danger
danger will robin's i mean this is like
signals flares going off everywhere i'm
with you there's all kinds of signals
here this doesn't sound right
um i mean is every woman from the
ukraine evil no that's not what i'm
saying
but there's a classic mail-order russian
bride scam
that's been going around for a thousand
years you know i mean it's just it's a
classic
so um well here's the problem
once someone has powdered your butt they
don't want your opinion about money or
sex
right so you have powdered butt syndrome
it's hard for parents to listen to their
25 year old kids
even when the parent is going nutty
nutty like your dad is okay
so that's the uphill battle you've got
so in other words if he was doing
cocaine
and you walked in there and and started
you know trying to be his mother and say
you're not doing cocaine anymore you're
killing yourself dad i love you
this is stupid you have to stop he's
probably going to toss you out on your
ear you've got you don't have position
of credibility in his mind to tell him
what to do right
correct who does pastor
brother uncle friend no
everyone in his life has told him he's
making a mistake and he's just starting
to push them away
which is why i've taken the position of
trying to be supportive
but no it's not when you support
stupidity and harmful things you're
causing them to occur
right yeah i mean you don't want him to
be under the illusion you think this is
a good idea
but you don't have to be nasty about it
and and cut off relationship
but um you know so i i don't know i
you know you could talk to a a family
therapist and get some input
that's better than mine probably i'm not
one but um
sadly i've ended up working in these
things a bunch of times over the years
as a financial coach and so i end up
right in the middle of it and so i end
up with people like dr john deloney
breathing down my neck telling me what
to say
so uh you know it probably what you
don't want to do is sever
the relationship but you have a moral
obligation
a love obligation to your father to
give him the warning
absolutely yeah i want him to be set up
if he chooses
to continue or chooses to separate from
anyone who dares question his his wisdom
then that's just on him you can't make
people do that
but listen you know i don't even know
you and you called here and i love you
enough to tell you the truth
i'm gonna you know i'm not if you hear
me do it all the time to people right
and it's not for the entertainment value
it's because i want them to go win i'm
not gonna lie i'm not gonna participate
and they're crazy and so that's what you
gotta do you just gotta sit down go dad
i love you
this is scaring me it's got all kinds of
red flags around it
my spidey sense is going crazy and i'm
afraid for you dad
i think this is a bad thing but no
matter what you do i'm always going to
be here i'm always going to be your
daughter and i'm always going to love
you
but you need to hear from me that out of
love
i think you're getting messed over and i
don't think this is going to end well
and i think you really need to get this
i think you really really look at this
with a solid set of eyes a simple
conversation
in person like that that's an act of
love
is necessary in this situation however
i don't think it's gonna work you're
gonna have to watch him crash and burn
because he's not gonna listen to you but
you are obligated to tell him